when i go i guess i'll bring it up now i
just googled the most dangerous animals
in the world
um and obviously like you you got you
you got your normal ones like stone
fishes on there box jellyfish is on
there you know black mamba or australian
all the australian ones uh then you get
number two number two mosquito of course
that's oh yeah that doesn't make sense
[ __ ] you're not number one
humans
we are
we've like killed everything we're awful
trust no one not even yourself
what's the what's the
strongest animal you genuinely
wholeheartedly think you could you could
be in the fight what
define beat in a fight
like to fist because like the animals
are going to be like oh there's no like
like like like bring it bring into
submission
kind of thing like what are we talking
about i don't know like or like run away
like the animal runs away or like oh
you're like
no just your bare face just your bare
fist and whatever is laying around on
the ground all right i got it uh
realistically realistically dog human
why are you fighting a doctor
or human yeah he's like dog
patients
not that i would
no like like a bit like a bit like if
we're not counting humans like a big dog
is probably the max i can go because
even then like you know
it's [ __ ] scary a big dog would beat
you up actually
i mean a big dog i mean i mean you're
like some really big dog yeah it could
really [ __ ] hurt could you take on a
wolf
i mean it'll be hard but i feel like if
you're fighting the final part of the
movie for sure yeah yeah yeah yeah i
feel like you could take on a wolf not
like
it's not a guaranteed win yeah that's
like on the edge of what i imagine if i
was fighting for my life is like a
hundred percent like success rate no no
but like you know but like could i
possibly get a wolf into a [ __ ]
chokehold or something go [ __ ]
[ __ ] ufc on his ass then maybe maybe
if i had the right techniques
all i'm saying human wolf versus wolf in
the octagon i'm just like you know
learn some bjj you have some bjj maybe
like maybe you might have a more
fighting chance you know
i think you're dead
because i mean how small do you think a
wolf is it's pretty big
on a sheep maybe you can beat up a sheep
beat up a sheep i mean not that i would
want to i don't think the sheep would
even fight no
i think she should just be like just
take me
just take me away right now
what about you connor what about you
what what what is the absolute max that
you you would think like okay i could
survive this catfish
[ __ ] off big ones i have some videos who
were getting knocked out by cats yeah
jump out of the boat yeah yeah
i don't even know i don't even know i
never really think about it well yeah i
don't think about this either
um
[Music]
maybe a very you know there's some tiny
monkeys very small monkey very very
small monkey maybe yeah that would
probably give me a good [ __ ] fight
oh yeah definitely it'd be three rounds
at least of course connor says
of course some of the weaker genomes of
some of the weaker ones you know species
of monkeys could you take on a chimp
[ __ ] nerve chimps [ __ ] chip what's your
murder yeah
okay why are birds so [ __ ] sassy
like what why why why are they so cool
like what do you mean by sassy they just
have attitude like like so many [ __ ]
i've seen like you fly i mean come on
i would be sassy too if i could fly an
[ __ ]
it's literally looking down yeah it's
like probably but it's like you know
like you like the birds of prey on the
sassy ones it's like the like the
domesticated the small the smaller the
birds like the parrots right yeah the
parrots yeah powers are [ __ ] sassy as
[ __ ] my [ __ ] god also they freak me
the [ __ ] out because their voices how
like how do they do such an accurate
like representation of like pretty much
every sound yeah our family used to own
a couple of like different species of
parrot um like a cockatiel and like uh
lorikeets and stuff like that and like
yeah yeah
something camera recommended yesterday
that was parent was key witness in
murder trial
as a woman is convicted of killing
husband
there's like 11 million views well what
is the power it's just like she did it
[Music]
i mean that's pretty [ __ ] cool i mean
like yeah because like my my parrot used
to
replicate like sounds that we would
teach him but he would also just like
pick up sounds through osmosis right
like i've told the story how much is
something no you haven't you haven't
told this oh okay okay so like we used
to own uh this like uh cockatiel which
is like do you know what a cockatiel is
yes yeah so it's like a sassy sassy
[ __ ] yeah yeah sassy
[ __ ] right but um yeah because
they're parrots so like they replicate a
lot of things so like we taught it to uh
whistle the adam's family theme song
yeah right so like every like we'd wake
up in the morning and it'd just be you
know whistling the animal things like
oh that's so cute but then other times
the sassiness would [ __ ] pull through
on this mofo and he would uh replicate
sounds that confuse the [ __ ] out of us
so he perfected uh the sound of the
microwave
not not just like he would replicate the
buttons like presses perfectly so be
like
but then like you know when it's like
finished and it goes like
it would replicate that perfectly so
many times where like oh i'd be in the
living room and i would hear that and i
would walk into the living into the
kitchen thinking that like someone was
there no one's there i'm like oh my god
it's a [ __ ] ghost and then i realized
it's my it's my [ __ ] sassy bird
and also like it would replicate like
the phone ringing and [ __ ] like that
they're really smart they're really
really smart and uh it would also
replicate uh my mum saying good morning
so it'd be like it'd just be like
i'd love to go like yeah
oh that's what i should have taught it
if if i ever get another lorikeet i'm
gonna i'm gonna teach you to go yeah
just to see how well i could replicate
that
oh my god anyway i remember there's some
like youtube videos where people like
mix it badly and they put beeps in it
for some reason yeah and when i'm in the
other room and i like the videos playing
and i hear a beep i'm like what's
happening in my kitchen
i hate people who do use beeps really
loud beeps in their youtube videos
yeah
i don't know
i was gonna i was gonna i thought you
were gonna go a different direction with
that conversation because i was gonna
talk about uh bass boosted monsters inc
memes because
how are you going to [ __ ] transition
yeah
you're talking about people putting
sounds in like youtube videos and stuff
like that and i'm just like yeah i get
it i st like on a tangent i still think
the funniest thing uh the one of the
funniest videos is just people who like
take bass boosted monster zinc theme you
[ __ ] love it and throw it into like
someone's sleeping or something
like to me that is just pete comedy
i don't know i just i just wanted to
bring it bring back the monsters think
bass boosted memes
literally had nothing to do with the
conversation and i was playing your mind
is just thinking about basically
monsters
i was playing 5d chess trying to like
relate these two things you were playing
5d chess we were playing checkers right
here
not even the same